[Music]
supports are supposed to be a refuge
from politics but in modern America
that's not allowed
someone's always determined to make
every aspect of life a PC hellhole the
Stanley Cup finals are being played
right now for Game two of that series
barstool sports partnered with the
Boston Bruins to sponsor towels for fans
sort of a nice thing to do is certainly
harmless but some people freaked out
demanding that the Bruins disavow
barstool why they're sexist or something
barstool sports founder Dave Portnoy
joins us to respond tonight Dave great
to see you always good to be here so you
have there the controversial towel okay
I can see that's a very sexist towel
it says pucks on net Tucker so that is
my phrase to score goals
you shoot pucks on net a lot of people
had a major problem with this with our
company on it now keep in mind we
weren't going out of the way the Bruins
call this there's a sales a sales guy
called me up said hey we need a sponsor
for the towel
are you interested so it sounds good all
our fans love the Bruins they love
hockey half the players in the league
we've worked with we've worked with
every team in the league we're huge in
the NHL we have the number-one NHL
podcast in the world spin Chiklis seems
like a natural fit it was a win-win for
everybody
I thought I thought but the PC community
people who don't watch are just mad at
life I had a quote that I read before
from 2011 which remains true people who
don't like life laughs they don't like
to laugh they don't like fun they don't
like men they don't like America those
people they hated this they absolutely
hated it they pull their hair out they
demanded answers from the Bruins turned
into World War 3 a lot of good press for
us because I don't care any press is
good press if somebody reads this and
has a brain like who are these guys
sponsoring likes hockey likes fun then
you become a bar stool fan I don't know
if there's a way to know this but of the
members of what you described one club
the PC community on average how many NHL
games do you think they watch a year I
would say the over-under is like five
and a half now there were some reporters
who cover the team that got mad but
people piling on saying I'm the Klan in
this and that those people don't watch
you never heard of us they are serial
protesters serial fun killers and they
don't even know what they're mad about
they literally wake up it's like what
can't get mad about today this towel
this towel is a very sexist towel it's
the most basic towel in the history of
towels they do it every game there's
banks everything wouldn't it just be
easier to say to the no-fun community
you're absolutely right you're in charge
I'm so sorry I hate myself for my sexism
I'll do better next time oh let them win
in the thing is it didn't surprise me
they get mad they get mad about
everything but we stay to what we do we
continue to get bigger we continue to
get stronger and all these people that
the face has changed but they stop that
they have freelance jobs because you
don't win by just complaining about
everything if I complained as much as
they did I drown in my own tears I just
move on and then they another thing they
do that point they say people are saying
mean things to us on Twitter well you
called me a Nazi and people like me are
like that's mean you shouldn't do that
guess what I get the meanest things ever
said about me I'm sure you do too I have
yeah if i sat and can worried and
complain is that Oh me me me you're
complaining about me I get nothing done
these people what do they do with their
lives
how can you get one lady one reporter
who wrote a horrible article about us
she said oh I'm getting attacked by the
bar stool people see this is what they
do you know how many tweets she had 5 we
have millions and millions of followers
5 people said that you wrote a bad
article you're gonna cry about that what
do you expect she attacks you but she's
the victim correct and that that is what
they all do and there's no way around it
we're a big popular organization we have
loyal rabid fans which have been
following us for 15 years know our true
culture know what we stand about if you
say I'm a scumbag they take that as a
personal offense it's bananas they put
they tweet in public it's a public forum
that they say they hate me and then if
someone says guess what
you're the scumbag they cry oh poor me
poor me just shut up worry about
yourself you don't have to worry about
us if you don't like the towel don't
pick it up don't pick it up it's that
simple
this is a sales deal the Bruins have
been sponsored by banks huge
organizations do you think that there's
not bad stuff this story I'll tell quick
one guy who wrote
this is true story tucker a guy from st.
louis who wrote a story about how the
bruins should be ashamed he was arrested
for robbing a bank he's a bank robber
this guy's a legitimate bank roast no
fun community the pc community and the
bank robber we like you a lot thank you
they portray barstool sports in a sexist
towel good to see you